[Music]
[Applause]
we've been held hostage by Aaron Rodgers
for quite some time now imagine covering
the Jets on a daily basis Rich samini
has been doing that for a long time ESPN
NFL Nation reporter joins us on the
program how's morale rich
dad I have not been out of my house in
literally a week except to go out to get
the mail and come back in that's been it
so yes I've been held hostage by this
what do you expect to happen today
I don't expect him to go on the air at
one o'clock Eastern and say I've been
traded to the Jets for this this and
this and there's still a lot of work to
be done I would be I think there's a
chance he may go out there and say I'm
going to play football this year which
he has not said publicly to this point
and I would like to play for the Jets I
think there's a chance he might say that
but he's not going to announce a final
trade
what do you make of the wish list by
Rogers
I think I mean it's a legitimate story I
I think it's been overblown a little bit
I don't think he said here's a list of
Demands I have to have these guys to
play for the Jets I think when the Jets
were out there in Southern California
last week they had a discussion on some
players that he wouldn't mind playing
with if he came to the Jets and I think
so it's more of a collaborative thing
and Alan Lazard who I believe they're
going to sign is he's a legitimate
player I mean even if they don't get
Rogers he's a legitimate ad to the
roster but then you throw in Randall
Cobb and Mercedes Lewis I didn't know
Mercedes Lewis was still in the league
but uh do you think that what's the
likelihood that they sign those two guys
that I think would be Overkill I mean
Mercedes Lewis is 38 years old I guess
he's a good blocking tight end tight end
is actually one of the Jets better
positions I I don't think they need a
tight end Randall Cobb 32 could he be a
backup slot receiver and play 10 snaps a
game yeah I guess he could but that's
usually a spot for a younger guy so I
think those might be stretching the
limits a little bit and as for Odell
Beckham I think at this point that would
be a luxury for the Jets I don't think
the Jets have the cap room to
accommodate him 20 million dollars a
year that's the reported per year salary
I mean it's he's not going to get that
but even if he got 15 I mean the Jets
they're pretty much pressed against the
salary cap especially if they get Rogers
so I do not see that happening what's
Plan B for the Jets
Plan B is now starting for the New
Orleans Saints the Derek Carr was their
plan B yeah yeah so uh they're they're
one Plan B I know there was a talk about
Garoppolo being the plan C I don't think
the Jets were ever seriously considered
Garoppolo I think everyone had him
earmarked for the Raiders which is where
he ended up I think they would be in
serious trouble I think they would
probably look into trading for Ryan
Tannehill maybe even signing a Jacoby
Brissette there would be serious trouble
and serious backlash from a very angry
fan base what about Lamar Jackson
I mean yeah I'm glad you brought that up
I should have mentioned him I mean yeah
that's kind of the obvious guy I just
don't know if the Jets are gonna pay 200
million guaranteed uh I know for a fact
when DeSean Watson was available a
couple of years ago this is before all
the off the field stuff came to light
the Jets did have some preliminary
interest at that point this is before
they drafted Zach Wilson once the other
stuff came out they backed off but I
think at that time they were taken aback
by the size of the contract he got from
Cleveland so I'd be kind of surprised if
they made a run at Lamar Jackson I don't
know how you felt about this but I
thought Derek Carr made more sense
because I could get four years out of
Derek Carr and and no drama now Rogers I
don't know how long I get now does he
give me a higher ceiling yes but I don't
want to start over again in a year or
two with a team that is going to be a
playoff team what do you make of them
I'm in the other school dance so I have
to disagree a little bit you know I see
the advantages of car also they wouldn't
have had to give up any uh trade
compensation for car would have just
been cold hard cash so that was the
other argument for Carr and I totally
get it I think he's a mid-level
quarterback who could probably get the
Jets from seven wins to ten wins but I
think I I'd rather take my shot with a
guy like Rogers yeah it may only be for
a year or two but I think there's a much
higher ceiling with it Aaron Rodgers
plus he could attract some players I
think he could Galvanize just because of
who he is a talented young roster I
think he would bring that element to it
as well and of course maybe in two years
you're staring into the abyss again that
quarterback like who's our guy the Jets
still have Zach Wilson under contract
for two more years they claim he's still
part of their long-term plan I'm not so
sure about that but you're right that's
the downside in two years you could be
left with nothing would they have let
Mike White go if they weren't confident
that they were getting Aaron Rodgers
I think they would have made a stronger
attempt to keep Mike White uh coaching
staff loves him locker room loves him
um Mike White I think would have come
back under different circumstances but
where's the opportunity I mean they say
that Zach Wilson's going to be the
backup I think Mike White makes a clean
break he gets a much better opportunity
in Miami it's his hometown team he got a
good contract so I think that worked out
really well for him any similarities
with Brett Favre and Aaron Rodgers aside
from the obvious ones
I'm so glad you mentioned that because
I've had so many moments of deja vu I of
course was covering the jets during the
far thing and the only difference really
was the calendar back then it was like
Late July early August but it was a lot
of the same stuff you know you know does
he want to play you know is is Green Bay
won him back you know there's the stare
down I I remember talking to Mike
tannenba on their GM many times over the
years he said he tried for three weeks
calling Brett Favre you gotta know for
three weeks straight and finally got him
to say yes so a lot of similarities two
different personalities of course farm
and Rogers you couldn't get more
different but a lot of deja vu moments
for me over the last couple of weeks and
this has been brought up uh oh you know
how's Rogers going to deal with the New
York media and I said well Dick Young is
not there anymore Mike Lupica is not I
mean I don't know how you know he's
going to be peppered with questions or
but you know explain the New York media
now dealing with Aaron Rodgers
yeah I mean I think that narrative is a
little overblown maybe it's just because
I'm in the New York media and I'm too
close to it but I don't think we're as
bad and vicious as people make us out to
be I mean you know yeah we ask hard
questions when the guy performs poorly
you know you get tough questions I mean
just as Zach Wilson you know he had a
rough go last year but I think it's how
you handle it ultimately how you play if
he comes in and throws touchdown passes
it's gonna be it's gonna be paradise for
him the fans will Embrace him the media
will Embrace him I just think Dan I just
think that's overblown a little bit I
just don't think it's that way
have fun have fun today and uh whenever
this happens hopefully you get out of
the house and uh you know go to go to
dinner or something and celebrate I
heard we got some snow yesterday
thank you Rich thanks Dan thank you Rich
samini been covering the Jets a long
time ESPN NFL Nation reporter